do you think the Geo guess a guy could
like have skills to work for like
intelligence agency or something like
that no no it's a different skill set
because have you seen how they learn
it's like you learn like oh look out for
the type of bollards in this country and
then when you find out the Bollard
you've already lost me yeah
it's like the like the [ __ ] things on
the side of the road like you know where
you uh just are on the side of the road
that like line it sometimes you know
like when you land your bike against it
or something and sometimes like a pole
yeah some but like not a big it's a
Bollard it's a small kind of stubby one
like around like waist
yeah they're bollards I didn't know that
well you learned something new every day
yeah so you know um like you know let's
say every country has very distinct Road
patterns and bollards yeah you don't
know actually you don't because you're a
human being and you're not weird and you
don't look for this stuff
um but obviously you know you can game
it and so while you're looking at that
you'll notice oh okay so if if Africa
has these type of bollards and Road
markings whilst you're studying and
learning this you're also just happening
to look at Africa a lot yeah you know
you can you can just learn yeah but then
you you inadversity you gain so much
knowledge just about like every country
you become you University become an
expert in like maybe indirectly like the
infrastructure the buildings of like
every every [ __ ] time yeah yeah if he
can recognize an image within like 0.1
seconds or something he can Garner that
much information that just means to
Garner that much information in such a
short amount of time that must be my
wealth of knowledge that he can be able
to like yeah yeah um but I imagine a
computer can do it better though if you
took a pitch of any place fed into a
computer there's I bet it could probably
get it more accurate than those well you
could probably just like reverse Google
yeah yeah I mean you know there's some
images of [ __ ] online you know and and
you know me these geoguesses are like
you know if they if the Geo guesser
isn't in the country which are a lot of
countries oh yeah yeah you just have no
knowledge of that country yeah you're
like Giga brained at like Mexico but
China comes up you're like
it's funny because like you I you look
at something like geoguessr and you
would never imagine that there would be
people this good at just like knowing
and recognizing the world yeah true but
turn it into a game and people will
break the system you know what I mean oh
yeah as soon as there's a game and a
high score people you can inadvertently
just get skills that you would never
ever think about getting through just
like traditional education systems this
is such a good game like yeah like the
concept of it is really solid yeah and
it's like anyone can you know I again if
a game is is is able to be understood by
like my parents within like 10 seconds
of explaining it's a fantastic game yeah
and it's a fantastic viewing experience
as well like watching someone struggle
with Geo guesser is fun because you are
you have your own thoughts right like
you're like oh I think it's here or it's
the country of your residence yeah or
you're just like oh my God I can't
believe it I live here you know every
time like [ __ ] Luxembourg comes up
you're like [ __ ] you Luxembourg people
for having a country that looks the same
as every other country around it and
then I won luxembourgie in the chat is
like how deep yeah laughs in high GDP
yeah no but like what was I gonna say
[ __ ] I have no but like I had a thought
and then it just like [ __ ] evaporated
I definitely do want to play G I guess
though I saw them dude you should it's
so fun it's it's as fun as you think it
is like it oh yeah it's like you're like
you you watch someone you play it and
you're like I think I'll have fun
playing this yeah yeah you do because
it's a fun game yeah because
could you could you like one of the big
things right geoguess is another game uh
language learning I think people have
tried to gamify language learning you
see that a lot in Duolingo right do you
think there are like some skills that
just can't be gamified like language
learning
depends on the person I'd say right I
think some people can really learn super
fast that way yeah and other people just
will not do anything for them yeah
because learning languages is is so hard
yeah it's a completely different side of
like your learning um compared to other
stuff like learning physics or learning
this it's a whole nother like it's a
complete section I think of thought yeah
it's a completely different type of
skill that I think just exists on
multiple levels like you know just just
learning vocab and like sentence
structure is not the end or be awful
language right like you if you don't
have an understanding of how that
language is used based on the culture
that it the language comes from then
you're just like then you're no
different to a dictionary yeah exactly I
mean English has always just been a
suggestion it's always been just a tool
to get whatever point we want to cross
and like everything no no because our
languages have like very rigid rules
English is literally just made to be
[ __ ] construed into whatever we need
it to be yeah think about half the show
should we say in English it doesn't make
any [ __ ] sense yeah like and new
words added all the time but also the
way that some of the the old words are
used are like okay I guess like that
that doesn't make much sense but okay
we'll roll with it yeah like one thing
that blows my mind is where a language
has a law in that language that
completely changes the way like you
think so I believe that like there's a
language that is using like by the
Aborigines in like Australia right where
instead of using directions AKA you know
up down left right and everything oh
they refer to it absolute Direction in
absolute Direction so by having a
language that is just pre-programmed
with absolute Direction like north south
east west you have to like just have you
have to like mentally have a compass
with you all of the time so explain
absolute direction from my understanding
it's like you don't have a left and
right hand you have a East and West hand
yeah if you're facing North yeah exactly
but if you're not wasting if you're not
facing north then you have a north and
south yeah exactly and it's like that's
just like oh my God like I have to be
aware of which way I'm facing in order
to tell you that I am holding something
in this hand exactly yeah which
absolutely like blows my mind but that's
just a thing also what happens if you
just trap them in like a box room or
something
maybe they'd have a hunch they just have
like a magnet in there
I I forgot I'm the holding this point as
well you know because grammar is like
optional in English a lot of the time
yeah it's really not necessary for
English to function it doesn't really
need any grammar yeah as stupid as it
sounds
you can get it's all just about getting
a point across in English it doesn't
matter how you do it well I I think
that's true for like most languages
right like grammar is in like well like
sentence structure and [ __ ] or yeah you
can just break sentences oh yeah of
course and it works like in other
languages it just doesn't work I I call
it I call it speaking Google search bar
yeah because like the Japanese is so
context heavy that that you messing up
the structure of a sentence could lose
context
in some cases but I would also like to
think that English does that as well
maybe yeah maybe if you said Pineapple
eat hungry then you'd be like well who
is it you yeah me and Japanese can be
the same way I know that Welsh isn't as
flexible to be broken as English is and
I at least that's all I know and at
least the very little Japanese I do know
it feels that way I don't know yeah I
mean I think in some ways Japanese is
like even more flexible than English in
some ways
um oh yeah because you don't have to
stress about who the subject of the
matter is in a lot of ways like in
English it's like I did something or you
did something yeah they did something
yeah but in Japanese you can just say
did something and then you can just base
based on the context of that sentence
you have a pretty good idea of who or
what they're offering how do you know
someone is learning Japanese they use
watashiwa yeah you know no one uses
no one says watashiwa yeah so you just
say yeah yeah yeah exactly it's it's
it's it's very context everywhere you
know because we learn from it in English
where I say I am going somewhere instead
of just going here yeah it's uh yeah I
mean every language is different and a
lot of it I mean I
now that I've Speak two languages and
you know learning a third they're
flexible in like different ways you know
I feel like English has a lot of
advantages especially when it comes to
just expressing slang especially like
you can make a sentence with just words
that have never been made and you can or
like words that just don't [ __ ] exist
yeah and you can get your point across
very easily yeah yeah exactly I mean
look at the North my dad uses words and
I'm like you just make [ __ ] up yeah but
I know what he's saying yeah it's like
like what you just like it's just like
instead of like
um you know I don't know you just makes
stuff up all the time it's so
frustrating obviously is he making stuff
up or is he just saying something that
exists that you just don't know no no
he's like I can't think of a good
example but like everything has to be
shortened or construed differently but
like some sometimes it just makes sense
you know because it's the feeling you
know like I remember before I have that
huh does Ty have that Ross doesn't
really have that you can't really just
bring nowhere near me no no we're just
changing the words in the con and you
still understand the sentence yeah
nowhere nowhere near as much as English
because I remember like
I remember when you know people started
using the word drip and I remember like
the very first time I heard someone use
the word drip and not refer to like
water or liquid you know remember those
days
well like I remember some I remember
like damn he got drip and I saw the
picture and I immediately understood oh
it's because he's talking about clothing
and I don't know why that just like
clicked in my head immediately but I got
it you know I I got it I immediately got
damn bussing I immediately got why yeah
you know like I'd never heard that word
before but like I understood the the
meaning of that word just by the context
it was being used in it was like it
wasn't just like me guessing it was like
for some reason that just makes sense
yeah I think that's just one of the
strengths of English is that the
vernacular is really easy to understand
if if you're uh if you have a native
experience yeah like you don't need to
be like ingrained in a certain like
click to understand that particular time
yeah yeah yeah exactly oh that's
interesting the advantages of English
English is very open that's why English
is one of the most difficult languages
to learn yeah well that's the thing is
we're constantly making up new words and
we're constantly breaking grammatical I
had to explain like copium to a Japanese
person and I was like okay like this is
a lull yeah like I don't realize how and
I like when I explained this it's gonna
it's not gonna make it makes you sound
stupid it's gonna make me sound dumb but
that's just how it is like you we just
use words that don't exist and then we
drop them but like I don't know why we
do it yeah we just do this it's not
until you think about it or you have to
explain it to someone where English
isn't their first language like I
remember I had to explain to my Japanese
cousin what this was yeah and she was
like what is this and I'm like yeah
that's a good [ __ ] question what the
hell is that it's like they're air
quotes but like how do you explain how
do you how you use it specifically oh
[ __ ] it's like you know what it is like
suspicious and you know when to use it
when you don't know how to explain why
that works I can't I know how to explain
it to someone who speaks English but
yeah okay but how do you explain it to
someone who doesn't know the concept of
what this is when a word is sus that's
how I would explain it
and then I was like wait now now I have
to explain what's up yeah what is
yeah it's literally suspicious but if
are you trying to make are you trying to
make Sasha more of a word than it is
this makes more sense because it's just
the shortening of the word suspicious
right but like if you were trying to
explain like to someone uh it's lit Fame
right like you're not gonna say like oh
oh it's a it's a family that's on fire
like no that's not what it means it
means something completely different to
what it acts like drip right yeah yeah
like how do you explain drip to someone
who's not an English speaker drip is
easy to explain the con the meaning is
just someone who dresses why do we use
the word drip I don't know see I don't
know why we use it but to me it just
feels right it makes sense do you have
these words in Japanese that come up
like the flavor of the month words and
leave I mean yes but I feel a lot of it
is derived from like slang or internet
slang that has some you know uh
derivation to it that came from like
some kind of like meme or whatever like
a lot of the words are from like
two-chan speak right where it's like
there's some posts from [ __ ] the
Linguistics that was just like one guy
started using it and then someone was
like oh yeah that's pretty cool it's
like sometimes sometimes in English you
just find words like drip where
um it's like put on a piece of clothing
you've never worn before and it just
perfectly fits and you don't know why
but it just like it's just like yeah
that works why does that work I don't
know why xiaomi Vu yeah
not this [ __ ] again anyway I'm sure
there are some linguists in the uh
Records that's Ken answer our questions
yeah but uh maybe some polygots through
like 10 languages let us know yeah yeah